citizens of the reject Nation as per
usual on a trailer day like this got one
up and then KY went to the gym called
Coy couldn't get a hold of John so it's
us two to cover what if season two what
if Koy this ends up better than season 1
well statistically we've had Marvel's
dead then we had Marvel's alive it's due
for a dead is it due for a dead or alive
was alive depends where we're at okay
depends on which order watch and then we
got echko coming up we know what
episodes they're going to be that are
coming out they relas all right we are
overlapping the
conversation leave a like let's watch
this damn
video oo Prett this kid puts on quite a
show was that Michael Douglas's I have
eyes on the target he does not look all
that
threatening different voice looks can be
deceiving your
highness are you sure you did not want
any backup no I'm great with kids dou s
man dude
o o oh oh it's like 80s Avengers it's
like the uh the the team you thought the
story was over
H art gorgeous was only just beginning
yeah they really up the animation I'm
actually this looks like love death and
robotss
normally early Illuminati got some Shi
back
in in the
Multiverse
waa Max
aventures falkyrie Mario
Kart CU corer dude who is this handsome
dog they got gold back that's impressive
itself that this is great oh okay yeah
look like G in the
planet oh sweet we're definitely getting
a lot more shuni which makes
sense C Yu's eror
oh good call oh a noden sun story 10
Rings oh my must be the 162 one we heard
rumors about Neil G62 oh do you see the
mech robot I've been looking for you
dude Mech raccoon new character for a
long time time time I don't recognize
these characters I think it's new just
be
careful I don't think I can wor what
might happen
next
whoa that was a great trailer sorry for
just yelling things that was a great
trailer DN
wow Darcy we got a code red Avengers to
has been overtaken on Christmas what is
this Cod Air no wait under sieg no no no
oh that's not it hey John mlan
[Music]
Focus I wonder how that strategy will
work for them a daily drop W the
animation look looks so much better I
wonder what episode drops on Christmas
you know what animation also looks
really good koi the space babies of the
galaxy shirt that is a
www. reation shop.com exclusive we got
other animated shirts over there as well
Child Protection Services one we got the
America's ass shirt of a homelander we
got the who influences The influencers
Watchman inspired we got a whole bunch
of other te's as well that real reject
is creatively involved with ourselves
and it is undoubtedly my personal
favorite way you can go ahead and
support the Channel with that in mind I
had no idea this was coming out to like
a minute before it came I called you I
was like hey I got rumors from heavy
spoilers thank you for heavy spoilers
for always keeping a good Lookout here
this was a surprising one because it
looks like what they're going to be
doing is carrying over some of the
characters and story lines from the
first season of wh if but then of course
we will expand by going to other areas
of the Multiverse and seeing different
Renditions that we hadn't seen before
what the heck is the planet and and Thor
Ragnarok my God that grand master's from
you know what I'm talking about oh I
know until you asked and then you asked
left my but it looks like that's where
that Mad Max game is I'll remember the
name of you don't need to com comment
for engagement but I you know let me
below I've never read comments yeah but
it looks like that's where that's going
to be from and then we got that new
character uh what do you remember her
name I do not they didn't say it I I was
listening very closely but you had a
theory I think this is going to be the
first character that's introduced him
what if that's going to be Canon and
eeko so I think they're going to be
doing a I think that's why they had to
get it out for
January so I think that character is
going yeah imagining that she'll be
integral to that story line and that's
kind of cool because being racist
whichever or I'm assuming all First
Nation people have to look and be an
echo uh no but I I think like uh it's
cool cuz like Harley Quinn started in
the show I like when characters can
start in one medium and transfer to
another uh like darc is in the comics
now there's a Scarlet Witch comic that's
got Darcy in it so we're seeing this
like you know Ora Boris of characters
like looping from medium to another
medium and cycling through uh I also am
really impressed with 162 getting
translated because that's one of the
best me have you ever read it nope it's
a Neil gaming six issue miniseries
that's hugely impactful it's really
special it ties into like if the year
162 had Avengers and how those
characters would like flourish it's got
a fun take on Spider-Man Hawkeye is
really cool uh so that's what I wanted
what if season one to be is the stories
that would like make nerds go oh my God
we're actually getting this that could
never finally make it to movies and
that's look like more like what this is
I mean I'm just going to assume too that
when it comes to Chadwick boseman's tala
tall imag that someone is replacing him
right like is it it can't be earlier
recorded stuff or is it you guys can
clarify that for us cuz it sounded like
a different voice sound like a different
voice and I also can't imagine they
would feel comfortable with trying to
chop up dialogue with someone that well
you could always AI it well that' be the
healthy way that's the safest timing and
everything I mean optic Wise It's ahead
of the curse didn't we just win that in
Sag that sag they want people to be AO
they uh they're actually asking for it
according to the internet uh AI is what
sag's goal was well I think this whole
thing was done via AI every frame every
an all the voices are actually just them
recording them and using AI to make them
say stuff looking at the C here's here's
what it is on screen that got released
uh I'll just put it on screen of what
the episodes are I feel like every other
episode is going to be some of the most
intriguing ones to get us to the next
one yeah I'm not going to lie man the
one about happy Hogan Hogan is sa
Christmas Hogan is Christmas I'm looking
forward to that because John favro let's
not forget he is the man who launched
the Marvel Cinematic Universe we always
go to like Robert dowy Jr who of course
is a part of that launch and I would say
is just as it's more integral in a lot
of ways but John fever is the one who
started it all ran you know really did
so to see how long he's been able to
long last through this they're not going
to get Robert Danny Jr back but excited
to see more Iron Man also I mean I'm an
Iron Man 3 Defender staunchly so a
Christmas movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
little Shane
black thank you thank you give me the
Man 3 sequel or saving fres uh but I
also wonder if we'll finally find out
who bought Avengers Mansion uh Avengers
tower has been bought for years since
Spider-Man 2 uh maybe we'll finally find
out who's in the the tower that he's
climbing through allaha mlan maybe Bruce
Willis bought the Mansion I got a
question for you do you think we're
going to see any King in here because
now would be the time to show some
freaking King cuz they could and if they
preed also like that might be something
that jonath major had done yeah
beforehand so I wonder if there was
going to be like what if there were 10
episodes he could film it in between
trial I I'm just saying well what if
there were 10 episodes and they're like
I'm say filment in between Tri I mean
it's until there's a ruling it's okay
that's true that's just science that's
the law in fact subpena blah blah blah
blah blah but I I'm also curious if they
want to lean out of the original
storyline and use stuff like what if to
I mean the the dialogue about uh
basically I don't usually do sequels but
things have gotten Twisted implies you
know the the events of four are making
things different than even The Watcher
so narratively I think this might be
more important than what F season one oh
yeah that that's one of the biggest
hopes too I mean because yeah we thought
what if season one might tie into
something larger especially when they
had like strange Supreme who I'm excited
to see back I'm excited to see him back
yeah we get him here we gotar we didn't
get in Multiverse of Madness also you
see how important my words are to Greg
he was playing the trailer while I was
talking interrupting me with dialogue I
meant to I did not I mean they couldn't
hear it you could have totally ignored
it so my most anticipated is the 0
Avengers cuz we're getting Michael
Douglas and Antman something I've always
wanted to see well guys I mean overall I
think this the quality looks a lot more
pristine and I think that's one of the
greatest Parts about whenever you get
like a sequel to an animated season is
you can update it the release date
schedule a little odd I don't know if
we're going to be able to cover them all
at time because they're releasing them
December 22nd and then they last till
December 30th and you know frankly if
it's there's something comes out on
Christmas we're not going to cover it
that day so just we love you be patient
with us we will do our best to cover
what we can when we can but it's the
holidays and we want to enjoy ourselves
a little bit too but uh yeah overall I I
was pleasantly surprised by this trailer
because what if season 1 was kind of a
hit or miss for me for like strange
Supreme episode undoubtedly like one of
my favorite things the MCU has ever done
uh but what we got here this looks
really exciting I'm a big tala Star-Lord
guy and I feel like we'll get stuff like
that here where it's stuff that we
wouldn't see and then also more comic
stuff like the 1602 excited to see
killmonger back uh obviously I think I I
Sid unseen the 80s Avengers because it
feels like that Meme of like what if
Kevin Bacon was like everyone as but
also because of the comic tie-in of
stuff that we'd never get to see of
those story lines that I don't think
will ever come to pass Maestro is I
think the thing the internet's going to
be or hopefully talking about the most
which is a supremely intelligent Hulk
people have been wanting a more Angry
Hulk that's the combination of smart
Hulk and he takes over the planet he's
smart but also vengeful and I think my
most anticipated as far as just like
dumb silly would be uh the Mario Kart
like that looks mad yeah dude well I'm
excited to get Sirus Hulk here in a
disposable cartoon series action yeah
yeah no we don't get Hulk back hey guys
thank you so much for being here what do
you think of the what if season 2
trailer um do you think scar is going to
show up IC so that's serious Hulk I hope
so skky Hulk
skulky hey
[Music]
guys